there are just a few days now until the
first flight is due to leave and
campaigners are doing all they can to
stop it demonstrating outside the
rwandan high commission and launching
multiple legal challenges
but sky news has learned of concerns
raised inside the home office where the
strategy is being implemented
we've spoken to a home office worker
who's been in the asylum department for
a number of years their words are posed
and voiced by an actor i feel quite
ashamed to work for the home office i
think this policy is disgraceful to be
honest there's disbelief this flight
will happen
the government says it wants to end the
trade of people smugglers transporting
asylum seekers across the channel in
small boats instead it plans to send an
uncapped number of people to rwanda to
have their claims heard it feels like
we're taking part in human trafficking
transporting people against their will
and paying another country to take them
the majority of staff who work for the
home office are in it to try and make
people's lives better but we feel like
we're being forced to implement a policy
that is the opposite of that
this is an iranian man who we're calling
bahram who we can reveal is one of the
first asylum seekers due to be sent to
rwanda
he's seen here giving evidence at an
international human rights tribunal last
november
he says he was a police commander in
iran but fled after refusing to fire on
anti-government demonstrators
he's now in a detention center near
gatwick airport after crossing the
channel but told of his fear what will
happen next speaking by phone through a
translator
sending me back to iran
for you i will face certain that i will
be executed that i prefer to be executed
in iran rather than being centered
wonder barham has been sent this removal
notice telling him he's on a direct
flight to kigali airport in rwanda on
june the 14th plans are so advanced he's
been told he has a luggage allowance of
25 kilos he's refused to sign the form
housed in accommodation like this the
home office says it will work with the
rwandan government to offer safety to
those seeking asylum and those
recognized as refugees will be given the
opportunity to rebuild their lives
critics don't believe that and say
they'll fight the policy every step of
the way lisa holland sky news